hey what's up my name is Samuel Letts I
do a Q&A someday and what's gonna be
happening right now
you're in luck by the way because I'm
going to be answering questions from
last week's Q&A Sunday which is cool but
the reason you're in luck is because if
you ask a question right now in the
comments below next Sunday I will be
doing my best to answer as many
questions as I can from you right now
commenting so if you've got a niggling
burning question around property
investment tax mortgages the economy
making money colabello so let's see what
we had last week the questions I've
never done a Q&A so no video well I'm
looking through the questions thinking
these questions of stuff like you guys I
just on it and you questions I can tell
that you're a smart following because of
your awesome questions so let's see what
we've got
NU'EST Clark Joel Barry
Craig alright let's take some of these
what does Craig say Craig a command he
says hi Samuel since watching your
videos and attending the crash course
last year I've been buying properties
using the beat ar-ar-ar strategy boo
good job man I'm glad you came to the
crash course and I'll be shortly
completing on my fourth property
purchase when we financing I use
interest only mortgages to maximize cash
flow and leverage as I'm looking to grow
my portfolio smart at what stage in my
property journey would you advise to
consider switching them to a repayment
mortgage or would you just wait until
the latter end of my life and hopefully
the properties have greatly appreciated
over time and potentially sell off some
in order to then use the profits to
clear the debt on the others keep up the
great work
Craig firstly congratulations sounds
like you've been doing it right brrrr is
buy refurbish refinance pull your money
back and then you can keep buying lots
of properties that way
transy question would I stop paying down
the mortgages personally I probably
wouldn't now I can't advise you on what
to do because what you do with your
personal finances is obviously your
decision myself so for the first 10
years of investing in property I was
just interest only in just only interest
only and the reason for that is exactly
of you as you've said because if I'm
paying down the mortgages I'd rather
instead of using my money to pay off
mortgages I do I'd use that money to put
down on more deposits to then scale
leverage grow a bigger portfolio get
more cash flow benefit from more capital
appreciation from more houses so it just
make sense
and even like very very wealthy people
like Robert Kiyosaki Grant Cardone like
they use interest only mortgages they're
not paying down their mortgages are
still leveraging other people's money in
the bank's money so I think the answer
to your question is if you get to a
point where you don't want to continue
scaling if you're important you think
you know what I don't want any more
houses I don't want to scale my wealth
anymore then fair enough maybe you start
paying down the mortgages for me in 2019
I did start paying off the mortgages I
paid off so many mortgages and I also
started lending money hello it's got a
bit lazy and I thought I'm happy now I
don't need more money and it's actually
Grant Cardone that called me out on this
in a in a private one-on-one mentoring
session and he was just like dude are
you over the hill now I was like I'm not
over the hill he was like well you
you're not scaling big anymore you kind
of slowed him down
I was thinking he's in his sixties I'm
still in my 20s like if he's still
leveraging and scaling and growing and
I'm now thinking I've got enough houses
now when I start being and that may be
my mindset is wrong maybe I want to you
know I want it I want to be as wealthy
as I can not just for me so I can have a
lot of wealth so I can impact more
people so for me are more about interest
only and then at the end of the term you
can just sell off some of the houses and
pay off some of the mortgages or renew
or the world is your oyster that's my
personal plan so I hope that helps
thanks for you great question good to
see you kicking ass come back to the
crash course Craig and let's celebrate
Lewis Clark love the content as usual on
15 so good to have young people on the
channel I was wondering what I should do
now I've saved up ten thousand pounds in
my savings through my paper round
I live in Scotland thanks Lois Clark
respect man I did the same thing I
didn't quite mostly same with ten
thousand pounds but while I was at
school I had several thousands of pounds
but dude 15 10 grand from paper hours
whatever you do you my friend are going
to be successful because to save up ten
grand from paper round's that means that
your work ethic is friggin through the
roof you know so and you respect money
and you're prepared to work so the
limits I have no doubt that you are
going to be very successful as long as
you continue with the work ethic
continue with the work ethic but what
you need to do now is you can start
working smart if you make ten thousand
from paper hours I don't know how many
papers you have to push through doors
just to make 20 pounds probably quite a
lot
it's probably like a day's worth of
pushing you know it's a lot so your work
ethic is good what I would say to you
now Luis is now you need to start
working smart you're 15 years old you
still very very young I would be I would
be wanting to get hands-on experience in
the property industry I'd want to be
saying right I want to I want to go and
work on a building site for six weeks I
want to go and hang out with some estate
agents and understand the property
market interest rates
I would I would start now working smart
and also instead of working hard for
money which you do at the moment which
is great start working hard for
knowledge
you know trading your time not for money
but trading your time for knowledge and
experience because I've got real high
hopes and I hope to see you as well at
crash course we're actually come in I
think I don't if it's sold out yet but
we're coming to Edinburgh soon to do a
crash course to get ahead if I get
booked on I'd love to meet you
respect Joel berry so I've seen the BR
our strategy is very successful my
question is what mortgage would you get
or loan would it be a bridge loan or a
buy-to-let
as I know when you read find out see it
will have to be by to let you to it
being rented out but what mortgage do
you get at the start okay so it's both
you're gonna start with bridge or cash
you need to buy the house for cash
bridging finance is the same as cash the
seller will see it as cash because
you're not getting a mortgage you're
just getting a loan a short-term loan to
buy the house when you're a cash buyer
you get discounts you can pay what you
want because you buying it cash so
you're going to buy it cash or with a
bridging loan then you're going to push
the value up you're gonna force the
value up on the house and then you're
going to refinance it on a standard buy
to let mortgage depending on the
property if it's like a HMO you might
need an HMO morbidity which is just a
standard buy to let buy to let mortgage
you're going to refinance it and then
you're gonna pay off the bridging loan
or pay yourself back the cash that you
put down and if you do it right you put
all of your money out and then you just
recycle and keep buying more houses and
leveraging your money so you can use the
same amount of money over and over and
over and that's how you strategize it
hope that helps Joe thanks to your great
question what else do we have is that
dis dare Vic
cool man he sounds like a strong man a
strong man he says heist I'm your part
from the deal itself what are the most
important things to have in check when
working with a possible angel investor
okay so an angel investor means someone
that's going to finance your deal so an
individual or an investor that's going
to say hey look the deal is good I'll
back it so exact you've said that apart
from the deal itself I'm glad you said
that because the deal itself is the most
important part okay so if you want to
get an angel investor I would say get a
good deal you've got to have confidence
if you have confidence if you're like
look this is the deal it's good and I'm
good that's all so that's really
important and then thirdly I would say
maybe get some third-party credibility
checks on it so if you've got a good
deal and you're confident maybe get and
a management company to say yes it's
good maybe get if you need a refurb just
show the Builder quote so you've got
third party maybe a third-party investor
to look over the deal and to confirm
it's good then you can go to your angel
investor and say hey here's the deal it
also be really specific in what you want
don't just say here's the deal what do
you think what do you want to do know
here's the deal and here is my proposal
bang bang bang don't pressure the angel
investor you want to say now look
there's a lot of people I could go to
and I want to put this out to you first
if it works for you awesome if it
doesn't work for you awesome
so you're not going to pressure them
become four make sure the deals good
have third-party credible reputable
people backing up the deal and then make
an offer that's what I'll say good luck
my friend if it comes off let me know I
want to hear the story okay SM says hi
Samuel could you do an interview with
Jim Hallie burn that would be really
interesting I know Jim I've actually met
him a few times
listen if you want me to do an interview
of anybody a lot of people say to me
Samuel can you interview Graham Stefon
can you interview Jim Hobart can you
interview this that the other youtuber
star property investor business person
Henry used to tell them just tell them
if you want me to interview Jim Hadley
bit and tell him just go I'm sure he's
got YouTube videos maybe he hasn't
actually but just email it go on his
website and just say can you please go
on Samuels YouTube channel I will
interview pretty much anybody I don't
care who they are as long as they're
going to be giving value to my audience
I don't care if they've got a big
following of small
I don't care if they're an expert or a
failure
I don't care all I care about is that
they'll be giving value and good content
to my followers so if you want them on
my channel just tell them start like
spamming the heck out of them saying get
on Samuels YouTube channel and I'll have
Jim on Jim's cool I know Jim Jim it's a
court like tell him and if he if he
wants to come up my channel he can ask
me and then oh c'mon respect ok best
girls my time you I found a number of
red to rent HMOs and landlords are very
keen on the idea but what do I need to
ensure them
I'm completely legit ok there you don't
need to convince them you're legit if
you think I to convince them that I'm
legit because they're not gonna think
I'm legit and they're not gonna think
you're legit and then you're gonna need
to convince them to be legit but if you
are legit just just at legit just be
normal
David think about it it's if I'm
thinking this person's gonna be thinking
that home crazy and you save someone
bother I'm not crazy
what are they gonna think they're gonna
think this dude's crazy because he just
told me he's not crazy it's like people
that always youtubers that always say
I'm authentic I'm authentic it's like
just be authentic don't keep telling me
how authentic you are because then it
makes me wonder if you're not authentic
and in the same way if I'm doing
business with landlords I'm not gonna be
saying this she's gonna get by the way
you know range of into a real thing I'm
legit you know just relax just relax
you're legit you don't have to be to try
and persuade anyone that you're legit
just offer a good deal or offer the
landlord a good deal and then if the
landlord says if you could deal but you
legit then telling you credentials then
tell him but don't go in there thinking
I got a persuading that I'm legit that's
that's my advice Bob wish it were the
best let me know how you get on okay
last one Aaron Herat says I've been
trying to find a good rent to rent or
loi lease option agreement property I'm
finding loads which could be good deals
but the problem is getting hold of the
landlord any advice on how to get hold
of them Oh Lord all right so you're
finding load but you can't get hold of
the landlord where are you finding loads
are you just driving through the streets
thinking that would be a good house and
you want to get hold of the landlord
are you going on Rightmove where are you
finding them listen if I see a house I
Drive by a house and I think that's a
good
you know and I don't want to get in I'll
go on land registry pay flea pounds and
I'll get the details of the landlord
I'll get all the information I need for
three pounds if I'm a right move you can
find the address just just zoom in and
look at the door number or then there
are ways on the crash course we'd do it
live so if you know if you haven't me to
a crash course get on the crash course
but generally speaking for rent to rents
and Lease Option agreements I find them
in places like gum tree on spare room on
open rounds the landlords details are
there if someone's advertising their
property to sell or to rent their
advertising themselves their number will
be on the on there so if you'll finally
get on these websites I could within the
space of 20 minutes I could find over a
hundred contact details for direct
landlords I know I just I just
constructed gum tree and sparrow and
open it I could [ __ ] their numbers and
then I could phone them up bum bum bum
bum bum bum bum and guess what probably
about ten of them would be like no no no
no I'm not interested and then one of
them would be like okay this could work
and then I jump on the phone or do a
viewing and then that one would fall
through and then I have to phone another
ten I get another ten rejections and
then I'd get another one they have
interests didn't then I got a deal so
scale combined with activity combined
with just picked up the cursor I don't
know if that answered your question
I hope it did my seminars are not
seminars okay if you come to a property
investors crash course or any of my
training programs it's a do winner so I
don't get down will do it in fact I'm
going to put a link in the description
to the property investors crash course
and those people say Samuel the crash
course is too far it's so far people
come from Australia come from Australia
so don't be stopped - the very first
hurdle because if you're stopped by
three hour car journey oh man
you we also stop by those tiny
rejections that you get give a like I
called three people and they said no
this doesn't work and then you're
probably then you're probably start
trolling my Egypt it doesn't work it
doesn't work just put in the activity
man like you've got the content you've
got the information put in the activity
get in the right environment I love
seeing you guys succeed
I know that's why you're here that's why
you're on my channel so listen let me
ask you a favor if you enjoy my YouTube
videos if they're helpful please do
smash the like burn also subscribe
turn the notifications on if you want me
to answer your question comment below
and I will be doing a video next week on
Sunday at 7 p.m. and I'll be answering
your questions as many as I possibly can
thanks so much for watching also the
crash course if you want to book on the
crash course I'll leave a link did you
see that happen do you know what that
why that's there because you need to
click it use your book on it
right now go ahead go ahead and go ahead
I hope to see you there god bless peace
out
[Music]